5 13 It's Friday morning and we are
heading into Fourth of July weekend so
to celebrate yes we are highlighting
some of the best barbecue spots in the
valley all morning long and this one is
a good one with a funny name though Ron
Futrell joining us live from roadkill
Grill in the Northwest Valley it is good
the name though Ron
oh no that's the name makes it here the
roadkill Grill John moles roadkill Grill
is where we're at to start things out
this morning we are smoking this morning
for Independence Day weekend hold on we
able to get some burnt ends in here okay
by that that's what's happening all over
the valley if you look at it what's
going on right now people are getting
ready for Independence Day weekend that
means get the barbecue out get smoking
Chuck farmer is here Chuck how you doing
this morning you're up bright and early
or is this this is not early for you
this is no one listens every day man
every day you're here good morning Las
Vegas good morning smoking let's go
smoking in here what do you say yeah we
got brisket we got beef ribs and we've
got some burn-ins going right now
so you can see we actually use pecan
woods so it gives a really heavy smoke
you're smoking we'll wait for it to
clear out a little bit before we post
time off here can you can you see in
there Armando
my eyes are burning right now Chuck you
know that oh you get you'll be crying in
a minute that's for sure you are crying
right now yes
okay so let's grab something out of here
what do you have that looks good
everything
this has been cooking now for about 16
hours
generally re-wrap them before we
actually pull them off but we don't have
time to do that tomorrow
they've also got out here I got to
mention this too there's sauce out here
I come out here just to get the sauce
sometimes the mild and the spicy stuff
both are great then I take them home and
I pretend like I made the sauce myself
nobody else does that do they chuck oh
yeah everybody everybody yeah just heat
it up say yeah I've been working all
night on it working all night making
this sauce no I got it at John Mull's
roadkill Grill okay beef ribs are
cooking right now they're smoking and we
are cutting them up
um so this is a good way to cut it let
me see is that a left-handed knife yeah
that's a left hand hang out this came
from Iowa keep talking hold on now you
got a greasy mic what are you doing here
all right so we got a beef rib you're
gonna slide right down there's one more
place where am I you gotta turn this up
this way stand it up like this oh and
just slide your knife right down there
oh just going the other way just go
right down the bone this way yeah
take the meat off there you go okay all
right now look at that look how juicy
that is no that's that's you've seen
good yeah if I hold mother what if I
hold the mic now is that okay
it's my fault man I'm sorry hey Nate
says hi and he wanted some food to take
back by the way Nate's been out here
before Oh Nate and he comes every
Christmas man we've seen that all the
time you got some food for him we can
take back to him
okay Nate they love you out here they
come do the job come on on the job Nate
come on let's do it again
and they still looks the same that's the
best oh he looks the same he's getting
younger I think all the time okay so we
got some of this stuff we're gonna be
bringing it back Nate here's some of
your haul from the roadkill Grill John
moles out here it's right in the middle
of the community so it's a little bit I
don't want to say hard to find but you
got a GPS you'll find it oh yeah if you
want it you'll find it that's the whole
idea and make it hard and make it good
you know what I mean yes yeah follow the
smoke
okay we're heading off to another one
here in a bit so uh let's get hit in the
road and we'll grab some food and uh
Chuck thank you I appreciate it man yeah
thanks Ron thanks Chuck appreciate that
roadkill Grill uh well-known spot and
yeah wash your hands Ron please before
you hop scotch oh man finger looking
good I hope Chuck looks Vaguely Familiar
he's been on Diners Drive-Ins and Dives
two or three times Guy Fieri yes also
loves the roadkill Grill because he
knows I mean it is a good it's the real
deal yeah yeah my meat consumption is
very limited but that's worth it
did you get ready for the fourth that's
an option you don't have to do all the
barbecuing yourself